that was a bummer of a game i'll say it
i'll start right there that was a bummer
of a game because patrick mahomes is one
of those guys that when he gets injured
it affects the entire league and it
affects the entire viewing of the league
prime time games coming up for the
chiefs the afc west is different it all
stinks
he's got that ankle injury already going
into last night's game and there were
indications that the ankle injury was
bothering him he'd been hobbled in each
of the last two games and he was a
different guy when he wasn't able to
fluidly and effortlessly
run around and look for guys and just
whip the ball out whenever he saw an
opening
and uh there was a concern on a short
week that the ankle was going to be a
problem and then lo and behold it ends
up being a knee injury fourth and one
from about the five yard line ten
minutes left in the second quarter
plunges into the middle of a line of
scrimmage on a called quarterback sneak
and at first there was no indication
anything was wrong and then all of a
sudden it's like uh oh patrick mahomes
is injured helmet's off he's holding his
head he looked scared they had the cart
out
and then he decided i am walking off now
you can see that they kind of popped the
knee cap back into place
so
and and you know the question is this
x-ray is negative
fine
mri is what's going to tell the picture
here because the movement of that
kneecap is going to potentially screw up
some of the stuff inside of the knee
cartilage and ligaments and other things
and that's what we will learn today how
long he's going to be out but you know
what the indications aren't nearly as
dire big cat as i thought they were
going to be based upon everything that
unfolded in real time okay mike so i
that that's a perfect way to jump off in
a discussion i wanted to have with you
the indications are that it's not dire
and that he could be back in three to
four weeks i think i saw a report that
matt stafford had a similar injury in
2009 he was back in three weeks if you
look at the chief's schedule they have
their bye week in five weeks so they can
basically kind of if they can figure out
a way to go two and two here in the next
four games you can steal patrick from
home six weeks so you don't have to play
till till december
december first against the raiders
but with all that said
and knowing the future of the kansas
city chiefs franchise and knowing the
price they're going to pay for patrick
mahomes do you think there is a
discussion when it comes to hey if this
has any chance whatsoever of being an
injury that could get worse he could
reinjure it he could then have to have
surgery and miss part of next year do
you think there's any way that the
chiefs say we are going to play this as
cautious as possible and not even risk
it a little bit and make sure that he's
100 healthy for next year
and and kind of push off this year you
don't the windows you got to take
advantage when you can when you have a
playoff caliber team but i think this is
an interesting conversation because of
the type of player patrick holmes is and
because of his age and what he's going
to mean for the chiefs franchise for the
next decade plus
yeah so you're suggesting that maybe
they should shut him down for the whole
year
is that what you're suggesting well all
i'm suggesting is everything i've read
about this and i'm not a doctor i just
play one on tv but i'm
all i'm suggesting is it sounds like he
could be back in three to four weeks but
with being back in three to four weeks
he's gonna have one of those big clunky
knee braces and and it's going to be a
situation where he can play and then
he's strong but if he reinjures it he
could be in a lot more trouble going
forward and you know he then has to get
surgery and now we're talking about
bleeding into 20 uh 20 season and we
always know guys coming back from knee
surgeries quarterbacks it always takes a
little bit longer than just being on the
field you know you saw carson wentzman
he comes back it's not right away it's
not oh he's back he's 100 healthy he
feels it it always takes a little bit
more so i'm just wondering if the chiefs
are sitting on you know friday morning
here in kansas city and saying we're
going to get this mri
if it looks like in any way that patrick
mahomes can reinjure it or get more
injured
you know even if we say he's 100 healthy
to come back do we take the cautious
approach
and you gotta flip it over to a home's
perspective as well as a business person
now as an athlete he's gonna want to be
back on the field this is a guy who
refused the cart ride he got up i think
he was in denial a little bit walked off
the field wants to make everyone aware
that i'm fine i'm fine even if i'm not
fine
but from his perspective business
perspective
he should want
to wait for the balance of the year and
not play again and not take any more
risks because the window opens on his
second contract as soon as the last
regular season game ends so if you do
have concern this is going to be a
re-injury that hovers into the next year
they're not going to want to pay you
until they know you're healthy right so
if you come back
and something else happens to that knee
and you do need some sort of season
ending surgery that's going to take 12
months to get back to who you were
there goes that contract that you
otherwise would get in february or march
so i and i don't know that mahomes would
stand for that i think he's still
young enough and brash enough and
confident enough in his abilities that
he can come back and he can play and not
re-injure it but it's a valid point from
both the team perspective and the player
perspective there's an argument to be
made that we just
we just make chicken salad out of matt
moore or whoever else we can find and we
go forward and we hope that our defense
can play like it did last night and we
hope that we can get matt moore to the
point where he can at least be something
you know maybe alex smith light not
necessarily patrick mahomes jr but
somebody who can move the offense who
knows the offense who's been there i i i
see where you're coming from but you
know andy reid this is this is the year
andy reid was going to win the super
bowl finally i mean from his perspective
he's got to be thinking let's just roll
the dice i don't know how many more of
these trips around the sun i'm going to
have as a head coach i don't want to put
a you know i don't want to put an
expiration date on his life i'm just
saying i don't know how much how many
more years he plans on coaching this is
an opportunity to build on what they've
done last year and this year and try to
get to the super bowl so there's going
to be some some tension there as to
whether they continue to go all in for
this year or or play it safe for next
year and beyond right because i you know
with the way medicine works the way
doctors work with the way knee injuries
work we're not saying that patrick
mahomes you know maybe 20 years ago
you're like okay well this could be
career altering it's not going to be
career altering but
if you it's kind of one of those
equations you have to figure out in your
head that if patrick mahomes comes back
this year okay you're back in the
playoffs you're competing for a super
bowl potentially but again if patrick
holmes is wearing a huge bulky knee
brace is he going to be the same guy
or
do you say hey this could then bleed
into next year if he gets reinjured so
we're not only punting on this year but
we're planning on next year as well
because that's the doomsday scenario
here the patrol homes comes back in
december and gets really reinjured and
now you're looking at surgery and now
you're looking at 2020 getting affected
and now you're going two years down the
line of this window that the chiefs have
and it should be a big window because if
there's one thing that we've learned in
the nfl is that quarterbacks can keep a
window open for years and years and
years look at the patriots look at the
packers the teams that basically have
completely different rosters guys that
tom brady and aaron rodgers weren't
playing with 10 years ago it's all
different it's all new so patrick
williams has that type of special talent
where you can say
if he is healthy
the chiefs will be in the playoffs the
next 15 years so why would you risk
anything with that when you know that
that's that's what you have in front of
you uh mike the other thing i wanted to
throw out there so you you mentioned
matt moore
do you think that the chiefs will trade
for eli manning because that seems to be
the uh go-to trade piece that everyone
wants to throw out there why not trade
for eli
well we tried to identify their options
at this point there aren't many free
agents out there just look at the xfl
quarterback depth charts and you realize
there aren't many good quarterbacks out
there colin kaepernick at this point the
ship has sailed so cutler trade windows
still open well
like i said yeah like i said trade
windows still open though a few years
ago the window would have been closed it
used to close the tuesday after week six
they still have a week and a half to do
something and yes eli manning's out
there he's got a no trade clause but if
i'm eli manning i'd rather go somewhere
where i play than somewhere i don't play
he looks so miserable sitting on the
bench last week in that thursday night
game the giants played at new england
and another guy to keep in mind how
about marcus mariota benched in
tennessee and he he went into kansas
city and beat the chiefs in the playoff
game a couple of years ago i mean the
the cupboard is largely bare when it
comes to available quarterbacks if the
titans have decided they're done with
marcus mariota why not take advantage of
a team that may be desperate enough to
take mariota for the balance of his
rookie contract as the guy who fills in
for patrick mahomes and if they would
make a move like that big cat that tells
me they are seriously considering
shutting patrick homes down for the year
they're just gonna turn it over to
mariota let's do what we can here and
next year it's mahomes and mariota walks
away maybe he stays at the back up if no
one else else offers him a starting job
but it'd be a great opportunity for
mariota because number one he'd be
playing and number two he'd be with a
coach who can get the most out of him to
the point where he would be attractive
next year as a starting quarterback yeah
i actually don't hate that you say a lot
of dumb things but that one wasn't one
of them so i actually kind of liked that
idea out there the but by the way the
titans beat the chiefs in kansas city
two years ago or was it two years ago i
lost on that yeah travis if travis
kelsey doesn't get a concussion that
game doesn't go that way i think we can
all agree on that that was the game
mariota that was the game mariota threw
a touchdown pass to himself wasn't it
yes yes yes but travis kelsey getting
concussed in that game changed the scope
of the game and that was actually that
was a weird one because that was the
bears then hired matt nagy after
watching him kind of blow the second
half of that game and the chiefs
completely lost everything uh on offense
but i like that idea i i think that's
not a terrible one
you're right there's not a lot of
quarterbacks out there it's just going
to be
the the way the schedule works out
looking at what the chiefs have in front
of them
they just got to figure out a way that
if they can they can tread water for the
two and two because they have tough
games coming up they have the packers
and the vikings and then they have the
chargers and uh and the uh
titans and the chargers so
if you can figure out a way to go two
and two there maybe maybe win one of
those packers vikings games
you're sitting at seven and four uh
patrick patrick mahomes has now had six
weeks off he's ready to go for december
stretch
maybe that works but
man i just
i know if i was sitting there today and
i was
you know general manager the owner
whatever it may be for the chiefs i
would take a good long hard look at what
the ramifications of patrick holmes
coming back is and if the doctor tells
me that you know this is a situation
where he needs surgery but he can elect
to not have surgery and play the
remainder this year and there's that
risk that he could get reinjured and it
could be worse
i don't know if i'm taking that risk to
be totally honest with you because he is
that type of special player and you want
him to be healthy
going forward for the rest of his career
and not have something derail this whole
thing because that would be a real
tragedy
last minute before we take a break i
want to ask you this do you have a
problem with the decision to run a
quarterback sneak with a guy who had a
bad ankle right into that wall of all
those large human beings no this is
how many times do we sit here and tell
coaches that they are stupid for not
running a quarterback sneak this happens
one time patrick holmes got injured last
week or two weeks ago against the colts
by just throwing the ball in the pocket
injuries happen in the nfl i don't think
if you're ever going to coach from the
perspective of we don't want to do this
because an injury could happen well then
you don't want to do anything you might
as well just punt it on first down
seriously this is this is the that was
the right play call of course there will
be some stupid coaches out there that
get deterred from using their
quarterback for a quarterback sneak but
the quarterback sneak works almost every
time do you think that tom brady is
going to stop quarterback sneaking
because patrick holmes got hurt like
that's if if there was ever
a lesson to why you should quarterback
sneak on fourth and inches just look at
what tom brady's been doing for the last
20 years it's insane
there was a stretch where he wasn't
doing it but like last thursday night he
did it 17 times and i i couldn't help
but wonder whether or not what he did
last thursday night where he had
multiple quarterback sneaks did that
influence other coasters and say yeah we
need to do this more often but i i tend
to agree with you injuries can happen
anywhere anytime any place but patrick
holmes did come into that game with a
bad ankle and we all thought when he was
down on the ground that it was the ankle
until we saw the magical shifting
kneecap and uh we hope that he's going
to be fine we'll be updating at
profootballtalk.com all day long the
mahomes injury and what his status is
we're going to take a break that when we
return i want to talk about last night's
game from the broncos perspective
because i think they came into the game
with the right game plan but once my
homes went out they saw an opening and
they just tripped over their own two
feet
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports